passif pour l'instant en france les
pouvoirs publics exclus le confinement
des volailles
mais le contexte actuel amène les
consommateurs à avoir parfois des
comportements irrationnels la
consommation de volaille a diminué de
20%
et pourtant il faut le savoir le virus
et détruit des la cuisson pour rassurer
les acheteurs les éleveurs misent sur la
traçabilité de leurs produits
laurent dit michael cariou les poulets
sont conditionnés prêts à la vente ne
manque qu'un détail ce petit autocollant
volaille française le logo a été lancé
il ya quelques mois par un club
d'entreprises de la filière avicole une
initiative privée à l'origine pour
apporter un complément d'information
avec la grippe aviaire ses initiateurs
en profite pour lui en faire dire un peu
plus
c'est utile de rappeler au consommateur
qu'à l'heure actuelle jusqu'à ce jour il
n'ya pas de cadre de
duke l'épave hier en france et que donc
les volailles française
il est évident qu'il ya toute la
sécurité possible pour conserver des
volailles français donc c'est utile pour
ça ici on insiste donc sur la
traçabilité comme dans la plupart des
élevages chaque animal dispose de sa
propre carte d'identité systématiquement
on peut remonter le poulet de là à z on
retrouve la carte complète la carte
d'identité comme nous du poulet on joue
donc la transparence de l'étape du
poussin à seilh du tout mais qui arrive
sur les étals
le centre d'information des viandes va
plus loin et met tout en place pour
répondre aux questions que se poseraient
les consommateurs un site internet un
numéro vert pour répéter inlassablement
ce qu'on dit depuis le début de la crise
se lever russe ne résiste pas à la
cuisson à plus de 70 degrés phénomène de
méfiance ou simple baisse saisonnière
depuis le début de la crise certains
producteurs de volailles ont vu leurs
ventes baisser de 20%